[Musique]
à
c'est la foire au rayon des poils une
véritable fête foraine avec fanfare
couleurs et promesses sur le marché si
on veut se magasiner une poêle
antiadhésive c'est pas le choix qui
manque ici on a choisi thèse dont les
prix sont de 30 à 110 dollars
définitivement oui un très grand nombre
de poils mais un très grand nombre de
types de revêtements aussi alors c'est
super difficile de s'y retrouver
il y a deux grandes familles de
revêtement ce tic téflon et ce en
céramique dont certains ont des minéraux
appliquée sur la surface en fait ils
viennent qu'à une texture sur la surface
dans ça fait des petites pochettes donc
une petite pochette n'adhère pas à
l'aliment donc c'est plus facile à
décoller c'est la théorie parce que
l'idée de revêtement antiadhésif ce que
ce soit en tiédir
leur argument de vente c'est que
l'enduit va permettre à l'aliment de ne
pas coller à la pole ce qui peut être un
amateur pour briser les aliments et
aussi pour que ce soit plus facile à la
vie
[Musique]
notre expert a évalué les 13 points en
plusieurs étapes d'abord deux tests de
cuisson avec des aliments délicat tout
les poires sans exception avec une
matière grasse ne colle pas apprécié sur
une study sait comment qui performent
sans matière grasse
s'il performe bien sans matière grasse
d'après moi il ya plus de chances qu'ils
vont durer a fait que l'anti adhérence
va durer plus longtemps vaut mieux
performé de tests - seles dans la poêle
légèrement préchauffé sans aucune
matière grasse contre faisait l'épaule à
la verticale et je laissais la gravité
travailler pour moi il ya environ la
moitié des poils qui ont réussi à la
ronde et un tiers des
f-18 ont réussi ce test
enfin test avec la pâte a créé
la pâte à crêpes vraiment sur toute la
surface plus de chances de à derry et ça
me permettait de voir aussi en même
temps si la coloration était uniforme
serait que je l'aide d'un petit peu du
fond pour que ça décolle et seulement
deux fois qu'ils ont réussi le test pour
moi le critère le plus important c'est
de la conductivité donc on a mesuré la
vitesse de pénétration de chaleur à la
surface les vitesses prat à 90 d'une
minute à six minutes et demie même si
j'ai un revêtement qui fonctionne à
merveille mais que la poêle chaude
tellement en manque ça me prend une
éternité à faire cuire les aliments ça
me donne rien alors ce que j'ai remarqué
c'est que c'est vrai que le fond foncé
réchauffe beaucoup plus vite même deux
fois plus vite que celles avec un fonds
qui métallique qui pour manger fleith la
chaleur
la plupart des fabricants est dit que
ces poils ne doivent pas être utilisés à
haute température
c'est très clairement demain c'est
peut-être pas tous les fabricants faut
pas faire chauffer à sec avec hargne et
d'un david puis faut pour surchauffer
non plus donc toutes les recommandations
ces gens à feu doux à moyens je mets
jamais mes aliments à froid dans une
poêle comme ça mais seulement on aime on
soupe d'huile d'olive on attend un peu
plus long mano zelmat donc il faut
préchauffer minimalement absolument à
moins de faire de la sau et c'est sûr
qu'à partir du moment où je peux pour
chauffer beaucoup la porte ça me limite
dans ce que je peux faire que c'est sûr
que si je veux saisir de la viande je
veux saisir même un poisson dès que j'ai
une chaleur intense je devrais pas faire
ça dans ces problèmes
leur grande faiblesse c'est la surface
de cuisson et malgré des noms épique
comme titanium quand tonium résister la
plupart ne semble pas bien équipés pour
de valeureux combat
donc on a accéléré le processus
d'abrasion et d'égratignures naturels
dont seront utilisés une petite ponceuse
à discute qu'on a fait rouler pendant
cinq minutes dans le fond de la poêle
parce que si ça sera presque en métal
alors que l'on est à lire la blue
diamond qui fonctionnait très bien
jusqu'à ce test là totalement échoué
c'est une des ping pour la résistance à
l'abrasion une poire dans laquelle le
test dans l'est s'est pratiquement
aucune place vu sa résistance à
l'abrasion donc on peut anticiper une
plus longue durée de vie
on cherche à attirer notre oeil surtout
sur des prétentions on voit le mot
garantie c'est sur quoi et dommages
indirects sont touchés et inclut la
garantie ne couvre pas la surface
entière des illusions sans faire mourir
ses 45,1 on paye cher tout est garanti
sous la surface entière des 11 6 qui
voient se briser
éventuellement c'est le revêtement chose
certaine par expérience pas longtemps
que j'en ai de ses poils on l'a josé
tout une image tout même si je fais
super attention ça prend une durée de
vie est terminée elle ce point là non en
fait c'est sûr que le revêtement est
beaucoup plus sensible que le matériau
ça va de 30 à 110 dollars est ce que
c'est trois fois mieux à 110 non il n'y
a aucune corrélation entre le prix et la
performance celle qui coûte prophot plus
cher ne colle pas trop formons
à la suite des tests notre expert
suggère de considérer deux modèles parmi
les moins chers la graine et deaton
diamond pour sa résistance à l'abrasion
son excellente conductivité est une des
rares à supporter la haute température
ou encore la blue diamond malgré la
fragilité de son revêtement et les la
meilleure au test de cuisson en plus
d'avoir une excellente conductivité en
terminant quelques conseils pour
prolonger leur vie éviter les chocs
thermiques ne jamais mettre au lave
vaisselle ne jamais utiliser distance l2
en métal point tu n'as rien d'utiliser
qui est abrasif fois doux avec ses poils
longs
[Musique]